This executive order, signed by President
Trump,
starts a new policy on refugees and immigration
in America.
TRUMP: "And this is the protection of the
nation from foreign terrorist entry into the
United States..."
But that's not really what's in this Executive
Order.
So let’s go through it.
First, the executive order banned all immigrants
and visa-holders from seven majority-muslim
countries from entering the US for at least
90 days.
There is no security benefit.
Americans are more likely to be killed by
their own clothes than by an immigrant terrorist.
Nobody in the US has been killed in a terrorist
attack by immigrants from these particular
7 nations.
But the US is now treating everybody from
these countries as if they are a suspect.
Computational biologist Samira Asgari said
she now can’t come here to work on immunogenomics.
Oscar Winner Asghar Farhadi can’t come back
to the US for the Oscars, where he’s nominated
again.
Sudanese Doctor Suha Abushamma hurried back
to the US to begin work at the prestigious
Cleveland Clinic, only to be put back onto
a plane out hours later.
But in addition to these travel bans, the
executive order also begins a fundamental
shift in American refugee policy.
The order halts nearly ALL refugee admissions
for 120 days, and admissions of Syrian refugees
indefinitely.
And it says that in the future, refugees will
only be admitted from countries that have
sufficient safeguards in place to “ensure
the security and welfare of the United States”
This is the opposite of how the US has defined
refugees in the past: people fleeing persecution
and violence that their own governments cannot
or will not protect them from.
And this comes at a time when the world faces
its biggest refugee crisis since World War II.
1 in 122 people worldwide are displaced.
And those fleeing the largest humanitarian
emergency of our time -- the Syrian civil
war -- are the ones singled out by Trump for
harsher restrictions.
If you’re worried about US terrorist attacks
like 9/11, San Bernadino, or the Orlando Pulse
shooting – this Order would have prevented
exactly none of them.
But there is an exception for some kinds of
refugees.
David Brody, Christian Broadcasting Network:
"As it relates to persecuted Christians, do
you see them as kind of a priority here?"
Trump:"Yes.
They've been horribly treated.”
The US will allow members of religious minorities
in the individual’s country of nationality
during the 120 day-ban,
and prioritize them thereafter.
Trump: "Do you know if you were a Christian
in Syria, it was impossible, very very, at
least very very tough into the United States.
If you were a Muslim you could come in, but
if you were a Christian, it was almost impossible”
In fact, half of refugees in the past few
years were Christian.
Refugees from Syria reflected the country’s
religious composition – almost entirely
muslim.
But all this aligns with Trump’s anti-Muslim
promises throughout the campaign.
Trump: "Donald J. Trump is calling for a total
and complete shutdown of Muslims entering
the United States."
Trump spoke about taking an “America First”
approach at his inauguration.
Trump: "From this day forward it's going to
be only America First.
America First."
This Executive Order shows how much that vision
aligns with the original “America First”
movement.
That movement sought American isolationism
too – they were against American intervention
in World War II.
That attitude resulted in the infamous decision
in June 1939 to turn away the St. Louis.
That ship had 937 jewish refugees aboard,
fleeing another hostile government: Hitler’s.
First, they were turned away in Cuba.
"The liner St. Louis, turned back from Cuba"
Then they approached Florida, but the US Coast
Guard, patrolling the waters, kept them away
too.
They eventually disembarked in Belgium, the
Netherlands, and France.
"...Jewish unfortunates without a country
permitted to land in Belgium after five weeks
of suspense afloat..."
And eventually hundreds died in the holocaust.
Since then, the US Government has been the
world’s leader in resettling refugees.
"...They finally reach a haven of safety..."
The State Department website still brags about
it, claiming 3 Million refugees re-settled
around all 50 states since 1975.
The statue of liberty bears these goals too:
a plaque on the pedestal reads:
"Give me your tired, your poor,
Your huddled masses yearning to breathe free,
The wretched refuse of your teeming shore.
Send these, the homeless, tempest-tost to
me,
I lift my lamp beside the golden door!”
America hasn’t always lived up to these
lofty goals.
But since World War II, we’ve lived in an
era where the diversity of who gets to come
to America has gone up and up.
And a Federal Judge stayed deportations of
those stuck in airports amidst the confusion.
And the Trump administration has already started
scaling back.
Reince Priebus, White House Chief Of Staff:
"As far as green card holders, moving forward,
it doesn’t affect them.”
The Trump Administration is trying to end
the era when America didn’t care what religion
you are.
Regardless where you come from.
Legal challenges and protests around the country
continue to try to preserve it.